(majestic music)
- Okay, greetings.
We're getting towards
the end of this class,
so I wanted to remind you
that there is a second exam.
You know that.
And I also want to remind you
that there is a brief written assignment
for this class as well.
It's not meant to be complicated.
You don't really need to do
any additional research for it.
It's essentially about
looking at the reading
that you've got and finding
some kind of a theme
that you think is interesting
in Ukrainian history.
Ideally, not a theme which is identical
to one of the lectures.
Ideally a theme where you've connected
some of the dots yourself.
It doesn't have to be an
incredible brainstorm,
just a theme,
Just an idea that unites other ideas.
And talk to your TFs about it,
that's what they're there for.
So this is not meant to be tricky.
It's just meant to be for a way
to try to rethink the class diagonally,
make some connections
that maybe I didn't make
or the reading didn't make.
Try to connect different
parts of the reading
with one another
in a way which maybe I didn't do.
Talk about it amongst
yourselves, not right now,
but talk about it amongst yourselves.
That's a good way to think
of ideas, is to brainstorm
what some of these things could be.
Might even be fun,
meet your classmates.
Invite that person you
always wanna invite for tea.
Here's your chance.
(student chuckling)
Who knows what will happen?
speaking of who knows what will happen,
it appears that a couple
of Russian missiles
just fell on Polish territory,
which leads us nicely
into our theme today.
What I'd like to do today is
I actually wanna take a step
back and talk at greater length
about the Polish factor,
just as I did a couple of lectures ago
about the German factor.
I wanna do properly what
I meant to do last time,
which is to give you a
sense of how Polish policy
after 1989 helped Ukraine
to become the state
that Ukraine has become.
I would use that to lead
into the main subject,
which is the 1980s, the 1990s,
and the formation of a Ukrainian state.
So from today's point of view,
November 15th or so, 2022,
where Poland is Ukrainian
staunchest supporter,
or one of Ukrainian staunchest supporters.
Where there have been
millions of Ukrainian refugees
in Poland in the last nine months.
It's very difficult to
remember that in fact,
Ukrainian national
identity when it formed,
was formed against Poland.
Against Poland.
And so the Cossack legend,
the struggling peasantry,
the battle for land,
all of that is chiefly about,
not Russia, but Poland.
It's about Poland.
And then the Polish Ukraine
encounter over the centuries
has also created a lot of the concepts,
a lot of the underlying political notions
that are taken for
granted in Ukraine today
and has been creative
in lots of other ways.
So I just wanna start by
reminding you of that.
I know that you know it,
'cause one of the basic themes
of this class has been that
nations don't come from nowhere.
Humans evolved once in Africa.
None of us is truly autochthonous,
groups come into contact with one another.
The alphabet was only invented once.
I can do this all day,
So when we look at a nation,
the gut instinct of a
state is very often to say
there was ethnogenesis
and a people formed a thousand years ago,
and maybe there was a baptism
or like some magical event
where we all started,
cherry tree was cut down, whatever,
constitution, you name it.
Like some moment where everything is like,
you get a clean, fresh start.
But that's not the way
history actually works.
Nations are par excellence,
international events.
And so in order to explain
Ukraine or any other country,
you have to get all the
international factors
into the picture.
This is something that Roman Szporluk
who was and is a great
Ukrainian historian,
always insisted on.
And it's true for everybody.
It's true for Russia, it's true for China,
It's true for America.
If it weren't for the
particular configuration
of British-French relations
having to do with the Seven Years War,
no America or some completely
different version of America.
All right, so I wanna just remind you
how important the Polish
factor has been for Ukraine.
You know that it was Lithuania,
which very quickly thereafter
formed a personal union with Poland,
which swept up most of the
territories of old Rus,
including Kyiv.
You know that it was Lithuania,
which very quickly merged with
Poland in a personal union,
which perpetuated much of the
cultural attainments of Kyiv,
including the language of law.
And much of the law.
You know that because of
the Polish-Lithuanian state
or the Lithuanian-Polish state,
Kyiv becomes a major
center of European trends
such as renaissance,
reformation, counter reformation.
Kyiv along with Chernihiv,
a couple of other places,
if this were a class
in Belarusian history,
we'd be talking about some
other characters like Skaryna.
But Kyiv is one of the places
where an orthodox world,
an eastern Christian world,
is bouncing up against
these Western trends.
And that's because of
the Polish connection
or the Lithuanian connection.
The idea of a republic,
which is very important,
Res publica, Rzeczpospolita, Rich Pospolyta
The idea of a republic comes from Poland.
It's not coming directly
from Rome of course,
it's coming from Poland.
The idea of political rights in a republic
which may not be held by everybody.
And of course the dispute
between the Cossacks
and the Polish nobility
back in the 16th century,
17th century is largely about
who belongs to the republic.
Who actually has rights?
If the republic means the common matter,
who is the public?
Who has access to rights.
Both at the micro level
and at the macro level,
the Cossacks rebellion of
1648 is largely about that.
If Bohdan Khmelnyts'kyi had
had better access to justice
by way of courts, if he'd
been seen as a noble,
then probably no rebellion,
at least not at that time.
The Cossacks themselves,
this particular formation
of Cossacks anyway
around Zaporizhzhia is a
result of Polish power...
Encounter of Polish power
with the Crimean Tatars.
They're living in the
zone between Polish power
and the Crimean Tatars
and they're learning from
both, adapting to both.
So Poland-Lithuania loses the Left-Bank.
I've gotten all kinds
of directions from email
about what I should do with my hands
when I talk about
Left-Bank and Right-Bank.
They say, when you talk
about the Right-Bank,
move your left hand
and then the students will understand.
But I'm just assuming
you guys don't actually don't even know
your left from right.
So it doesn't matter what I do.
I'm assuming you're like my kids.
They're like, if I say
left, they go right,
They go da, da, da, da.
So I'm just gonna do
whatever I want with my hands
when I talk about...
But the eastern part of Ukraine,
Poland loses, the Left-Bank
is lost in the 1660s, 1670s.
The Right-Bank is lost
about a century later
when Poland is partitioned 1770s, 1790s.
There are four or 500 years
here that one has to account for
where the Polish factor
is very, very direct.
And even after Poland no longer exists,
as we've talked about,
it's still the Polish aristocracy
that owns much of the land
Right-Bank, Ukraine,
all the way up to the
Bolshevik Revolution.
So there too, there's an important idea
of property rights
and the desire of Ukrainian peasants
to have to have property.
Then there's also this minor current,
which becomes major later on,
which is Galicia Volhynia.
Halychyna (indiscernible) Galicia.
Which is part of Poland known
as Czerwona Ruś
Red Ruthenia.
It's part of Poland from the 1340s onward,
and then is part of the Habsburg monarchy,
and then is part of Poland again.
And then that region Halychyna Galicia
becomes part of the Soviet Union
after the Second World War.
And then is much of what we
now call Western Ukraine.
So I'm just reminding you,
I don't want you to forget any of this
when we enter into the modern period.
'Cause there's this temptation
in the 20th century,
this kind of unhealthy temptation to say,
well something has just happened
and now everything else is gone.
Like the First World War,
the 'war to end all wars,'
And the Second World War was
thought to reset everything.
And then the Cold War came to an end
and history itself supposedly
then also came to an end.
All these mental resets.
But there's no way to understand Ukraine
without this long trajectory.
Which of course can be
interpreted in various ways.
But it's uncontroversial,
and I think incontrovertible to say,
without the Polish factor in the long run,
there wouldn't be a Ukraine of the kind
that we now have.
So what I wanna explain now
is the thing that I was very
hasty about the last time,
which is how Polish foreign policy
and Polish thinking about Ukraine
had a decisive and I
would even venture to say
world historical effect
in the 80's and in 1990s.
And to do this,
I need to draw your
attention to a certain...
I'm gonna have to make a
certain anti-imperial point,
which is this.
When people talk about
the period '89 to '91,
now they talk about Moscow and Washington,
which is already problematic,
because what happened in '89 to '91
had a lot to do with
Warsaw, Prague, Budapest,
Vilnius, a lot of other places.
But more than that,
people talk about Moscow and Washington
as though they knew what they were doing.
Especially with respect to Washington.
There's this very strange
view which holds that...
The Soviet Union broke up in
1991 because the Americans,
and they were all powerful
and they machinated...
is that a word?
It was all (indiscernible)
like they were behind everything
and somehow there was a plot
and they wanted to break
the Soviet Union up.
And that's just not so.
That's just not so.
American policy at the time
was to hold the Soviet Union together.
And the period '89 to '91
was a series of one unexpected
event after the other,
which people reacted to
sometimes very skillfully.
The Bush Administration
reacted very skillfully
to an unexpected situation,
especially with respect to
the unification of Germany.
There were some good diplomats
at work, no denying that,
but basically nobody expected
the East European revolutions of '89.
And even after the East
European revolutions of '89,
very, very few people
expected the Soviet Union
to fall apart in 1991.
And the American political class
was working with great determination
in the opposite direction
to try to keep Gorbachev in power
and to try to keep the
Soviet Union together.
I mention all that because
this is not a class
about the Cold War,
although Arne Westad teaches
great classes about this.
This is a class about Ukraine.
But it's very important to
see that these countries,
which where people lose focus,
what people remember about '89 to '91.
I mean, what's one image from '89 to '91?
- [Student 2] The fall of the Berlin Wall.
- Yes, David Hasselhoff.
Sorry that joke did not work.
That joke was totally out...
You know who David Hasselhoff is?
So you know that he
played on the Berlin Wall.
Yeah, so David Hasselhoff
here is like KITT
and Knight Rider.
That was Knight Rider, yeah.
Because in Germany he's a rock star.
And in Austria he's a rock star.
And so when the Berlin wall fell,
David Hasselhoff went and played...
You don't need David Hasselhoff,
but the image is the Berlin Wall falling.
Which A, it didn't fall.
It's a very dramatic image,
The people... And then it fell.
It didn't actually fall.
They opened the gates
and they opened the gates,
because an Italian
journalist asked a question
and the East German official
gave an ambiguous answer
and people went to the gates
and the border guards opened them
and then they charged into...
But that's not how communism
really came to an end.
The reason why we like Berlin Wall
is because it's very dramatic, right?
And because it's Germany
and Germany's a big important country.
But the real action at
the end of the Cold War
was not actually in Germany.
The real action at the
very end of the Cold War
was much more in Poland
than anywhere else.
And when it comes to the
end of the Soviet Union,
we can't understand that
part without Ukraine.
I'm sure you all get that.
So the point that I wanna make now
is that there was an interior
development inside Poland,
or among Poles that was running
against the main current
of communism and also
of nationalism.
And if that sounds contradictory,
keep in mind that one of the ways
that communism was trying to stay in power
by the 70s and 80s
was as a kind of boring, homogenizing
version of nationalism.
A nationalism which looked
back to uncontroversial symbols
that wouldn't defend the people in Moscow.
A communism that took
credit in the Polish case
for making the country
nationally homogeneous
I.e. without Germans, without Ukrainians,
and without Jews.
A communism which seemed
like it could go on forever.
And indeed that is what
the 70s and 80s felt like.
So in order to... (foot bumping desk)
Sorry.
In order to understand
the mood shift of '89,
one has to grasp that
it really did seem like
that version of communism
could go on forever.
It really did seem like
that they were winning,
as they put it, the correlation of forces
was in their favor.
That they were winning in the third world,
that they would keep
winning in the third world.
That their economy was big
comparable to the American economy.
The CIA thought that
the Soviet economy was,
in 1975, was 57% of the
size of the US economy,
which it almost certainly wasn't.
The East German economy
was thought of as being...
I forget, but it's like the
fifth, sixth, seventh, eighth,
one of the biggest economies in the world,
or at least per capita.
Those things were really not true,
but that's really how it seemed.
The version of communism
which was going on in Poland,
offers a kind of exception.
And that exception was Solidarity.
And I have to mention Solidarity.
I realize this is a class about
Ukraine, not about Poland,
but the Solidarity movement in Poland.
Which one of your TAs,
whose name I won't mention
since I've learned I shouldn't
mention anybody's name,
'cause then they get
like millions of emails.
But one of your TAs who
shall now remain nameless,
works on this subject.
I'll be very happy to
talk to you about it.
And you can guess which one.
So Solidarity is very special,
because what Solidarity does
is that it opens a window
where discussions of difficult questions
having to do with communism
and nationalism are possible.
Solidarity is possible,
because the Polish workers above all,
who gets left outta the
story of the revolution?
The workers.
There was only one working
class revolution ever,
and it was in Poland.
And who gets left out of the story?
Poland and the workers.
'89 it's all about the
clever guys in the suits.
No, it's fundamentally about
a working class revolution,
which began in Poland,
which made it seem possible
that communism could come to an end.
So what was special about Poland was this,
in the 70s,
the Polish regime was operating basically
the way that other communist regimes
in Eastern Europe were operating
and the way Brezhnev
wanted them to operate.
Namely, no discussions of ideology,
marxism is dead,
no serious attempts to reform the system.
Reform is dangerous,
if you try to reform,
we can invade you as in
Czechoslovakia in 1968.
That's the Brezhnev doctrine.
The country seems to be getting
a little bit out of line
than fraternal assistance.
So the Polish government,
which was led by a man
called Edward Gierek
took this to its logical extreme and said,
this is all about
consumerism and nationalism.
Then what we're gonna do
is we're gonna borrow...
And you can see how this is
just the next logical step.
We're gonna borrow a lot
of money from the West,
we're gonna let people
travel a little bit more,
we're gonna work on refrigerators and cars
and consumer goods, try to provide them.
And for about five years,
this seemed like it was going very well.
We're talking about the 1970s now.
After about five years of
this you get oil crisis,
you get Poland not being able to pay back
its hard currency debts.
So hard currency debt
may sound like a technical term.
And up until the moment when
you don't have hard currency.
So if you borrow money in
dollars or German marks
as they were at the time,
you have to be able to
pay it back in dollars
or German marks,
which means that you have
to be able to sell something
which will give you
dollars or German marks,
which the Poles were
not really in a position
to be able to do.
They over-invested in heavy industry.
They didn't invest in things
that they could actually sell
like textiles and agriculture.
So they found the economy by 1979
went into the red GDP in
1979 in Poland, was negative.
Solidarity begins as an economic protest
against price increases.
But it morphs very quickly
into a political movement
which demands the right to form a free
and independent labor union.
That's what Solidarity is,
it's a labor union.
But also other political rights
like the release of political prisoners
and freedom of speech.
Solidarity exists in
Poland for about 16 months
from August of 1980
until Marshal Law's
declared in December of 1981.
And during the 16 month period,
there is a free discussion in the press,
in public among people of
many difficult questions,
including the Ukrainian question.
And Solidarity itself
does some very interesting things
with respect to Ukraine.
Like for example, express its solidarity
with the nations of the Soviet Union.
I'm sure that sounds incredibly...
Like an incredibly bland formulation now.
But in 1981, that was an
extraordinary thing to say,
to recognize the nations
of the Soviet Union.
And I'll talk more about this in a moment,
but in Solidarity newspapers
and even in public discussions,
many of the difficult questions
of Polish-Ukrainian relations,
which we've talked about,
like the ethnic cleansing in
Volhynia, Operation Vistula,
The interwar Poland
and its oppressive policies
towards Ukrainians.
Many of these things were discussed,
Many of the things were worked out.
People in Solidarity
had the sense correctly
that the Ukrainian question
was being used against them.
That the Ukrainian question was being used
to keep Poles in their place.
How did they know to do this?
And this is the part that I
did in 45 seconds last time.
And I wanna spend a
few more moments on it.
This is the part about where
I was trying to make the point
that history doesn't come to an end.
And so you should plan for the future,
Which is, I'm sure that's
what your mom and dad
tell you all the time anyway.
Sorry, I'm not gonna do an in imitation
of all of your parents,
I have limited time.
I only know some of your parents.
This is being filmed.
The point though
and it's a very serious point,
is that if you think
history is coming to an end
or if there's only one
destination for history,
then political imagination
just disappears.
Just disappears.
And if you're in a complaining mood,
you might say,
oh, this is the story of my lifetime.
Because in the United States,
everyone said history
came to an end in 1989
and then everyone stopped
thinking about the future
and here we are.
That may give you an intuitive sense
of what I'm talking about.
But what happened in the Polish case
is that a group of...
A very small group of Polish thinkers
centered around this
journal called Kultura,
rethought the issue of Poland
and its Eastern neighbors.
And in particular they rethought
the issue of Poland and Ukraine.
And the men and women who did this
were coming out of a liberal status milieu
in Interwar Poland.
They didn't come from nowhere.
These were the same people
who in Interwar Poland,
thought there should be
autonomy for Galicia.
We have to take the Ukrainian
questions seriously.
Some of them were active
in the attempt to create
autonomy in Volhynia.
Some of them were thinking about
how we might break the Soviet Union apart.
This group survives... Most of them,
survives a second World War.
They end up abroad
in a suburb of Paris
called Maisons-Laffitte
which is chiefly known
for its horse races.
In case you go there,
that's something you could do.
The food's also nice.
So they went to Maisons-Laffitte
'cause they couldn't
afford the rent in Paris.
And how did they get to Paris?
Here's how they got to Paris.
First you serve in the Polish army.
Second Germany invades,
third, you retreat to the East,
fourth Soviet Union invades,
fifth, you get deported to the Gulag,
sixth after you deport to the Gulag,
Germany invades the Soviet Union.
Seventh, Stalin decides
that he needs you to fight
after all on his side.
Eighth, you're allowed to form an army,
but not one that's gonna
fight on the eastern front,
only on the western front.
What number am I on?
- [Students In Unison] Nine.
- Ninth you form up...
You're released from the Gulag.
You probably leave your
wives and children behind.
You're released from the Gulag.
Men.
You probably leave your wives
and children behind the Gulag,
You form up...
That part of the story
always gets left out.
But if you think about
it for just a minute,
you realize, well wait a minute,
where were the women and children?
Oh, they were still in the Gulag.
So you form up...
That's what heroism looks like.
You form up in an army,
in a base in southern Russia.
You make your way through
Iran, Iraq, Palestine,
Northern Africa, you fight on
the western front in Italy,
take terrible casualties,
especially at the famous
battle called Monte Cassino.
That's the standard trajectory.
And then after having done all of that,
of course the Soviets win
the war on the Eastern Front,
Poland goes communist, you can't go home.
So simple little story.
That's the basic trajectory
of a lot of these folks.
They're variations, but
that's the basic idea.
So these are people who are
very often Russian speakers
Jerzy Giedroyc's the
most important of them,
born in Minsk.
Russian, probably his
preferred language of reading.
Had a Russian wife for a while.
Jozef Czapski, probably the
second most important of them.
Born in what's now Belarus.
Very extremely cosmopolitan origins,
chooses Polish identity.
These are people who knew Russian,
who knew Eastern Europe,
who had a sense that Poland...
Their sensibility about Poland
was everything opposite.
Everything contrary to the notion
that it was some kind of small
Central European ethnically
homogeneous entity.
But their achievement,
their achievement was to
think about the future
and to imagine what it would be like to be
an independent Poland in Eastern Europe.
In other words, they went beyond
the obvious grievance position.
I mean, it is totally obvious.
Poland lost half its territory,
It lost millions of people during the war.
It was an ally...
The whole second World War
was fought because of Poland.
And even though it was an ally,
it still ends up under Soviet rule.
The entirety of Warsaw is
destroyed at the end of the war.
So there are things to
have grievances about,
but they, if you want,
quite calmly or even coldly,
moved beyond the grievance.
Oh, and the point is,
a lot of these grievances
could be directed against Ukrainians.
Ukrainians got Western Ukraine.
That's not what they called it.
Ukrainians got the districts
of Małopolska wschodnia
they got Wołyń,
the Ukrainians got this territory from us.
So a lot of these grievances
could be directed against Ukrainians.
What Kultura did was
they moved beyond the grievance position
into what they portrayed
as a geopolitical position,
which is interesting.
They said, okay, if there's
gonna be an independent Poland,
how is that gonna be possible?
How is it gonna be possible?
It's gonna be possible with
an independent Lithuania,
independent Belarus and
especially independent Ukraine.
And the reason why this is so important,
this is their argument,
is imperialism,
imperialism.
Russian imperialism will only be blocked
by an independent Ukraine.
Polish imperialism
will only be blocked by
an independent Ukraine.
There's a very important
degree of self-understanding
and self-knowledge in this.
When I went to visit
Jerzy Giedroyc in Paris
in Maisons Laffitte in 1994,
for the first time.
He had no idea who I was.
He didn't have a perfectly
high opinion of Americans
and I was just some kid.
But I told him what I was working on.
At the time I was working on Polish...
Contemporary Polish diplomatic relations
with Ukraine and Lithuania.
And he said,
he gave me this little
speech in which he said,
Proszę Pana
You've probably heard a great deal
about the romantic
Polish legacy in the East
and all of the terrible suffering
of the Poles in the East.
And he said,
This is all nonsense.
Which is a very strong thing,
to deny the entire frontier
rhetoric of your own country.
Very strong position.
To take Polish romanticism and say,
just gonna push that aside.
Very strong position,
very strong position.
And so they start with
the geopolitical logic
and the whole time,
what they say is,
this is all...
Okay, this is all just cold
hard geopolitical reasoning.
That's what they say.
But in order to carry this out,
in order to make Ukraine real,
they engage with Ukraine.
And again, for a lot of them,
they've been already
doing this for decades.
So Giedroyc took a class
in Ukrainian history
in I think 1924 in Warsaw.
Okay, so classes in Ukrainian
history, they're important.
He took a class in Ukrainian history
as a law student in Warsaw.
He was engaged with a Galician
question in interwar Poland.
It wasn't the first time
they thought about Ukraine,
but they engaged with Ukraine
in the sense that they publish,
I mentioned this last time,
they published Ukrainian writers,
They published George Shevelov,
who is a brilliant Ukrainian philologist.
They published Borys Levyts'kyi,
he was a otherwise unknown,
but very talented sovietologists
or contemporary historian
in the Soviet Union.
They publish a thousand pages
of what Giedroyc calls
the 'Executed Renaissance,'
which is the murdered
or some of them committed suicide.
But the murdered or exiled
Soviet Ukrainian writers
of the 20s,
the 20s and early 30s.
In 1952, they publish a letter.
I mentioned this last time.
They publish a letter saying,
let the blue yellow flag
fly over Lwów
which is an extraordinary... At the time,
an extraordinary thing to say.
And then they back that up
over the course of the 60s and 70s
with a long series of
geopolitical articles.
But the entire time they're doing this,
they're also publishing.
And here comes the slightly...
The part which is slightly impalpable,
but they also befriend Ukrainian writers.
They befriend Ukrainian writers.
Ukrainian writers become
part of their milieu
over the course of the decades,
these friendships build up
and Ukraine becomes real for them.
So the entire time they're
saying this is just like a
cold-hearted, you know,
we're just cold-hearted geo politicians,
we're just doing this in the
interest of the Polish state.
And that's some of the truth,
maybe even most of the truth.
But that calculation,
I mean, you might even
say that geopolitics
was only possible with the
help of the personal dimension.
They couldn't have done it themselves.
They needed to do it with the Ukrainians,
And so a lot of Ukrainians
found their voice.
Oh and I almost forgot to say,
the person, he only published
one article in Kultura
to my knowledge.
But the person who was
often guiding Giedroyc
about who to publish
on the pages of Kultura
was this fellow Ivan Rudnyts'kyi
who I mentioned towards the
beginning of the course.
Ivan Rudnyts'kyi who comes
from this Ukrainian family,
Jewish origin.
His mother was Milena Rudnyts'ka,
powerful orator,
parliamentarian interwar Poland.
It was Ivan Rudnyts'kyi who in
the 60s and 70s in particularly
was winning the debate in the diaspora
about what kind of nation Ukraine was.
He was also advising Giedroyc
about who to publish in Ukraine.
Rudnyts'kyi, you know who Rudnyts'kyi is,
because you're doing the reading, right?
I don't have to tell you who...
You're doing the reading.
Yes, I like the smiles when I say that.
I'm not gonna think too hard
about what those smiles mean,
but I like them.
So, Rudnyts'kyi who's the
most influential voice
on behalf of the argument
that Ukraine is a political nation
and not an ethnic one,
is involved with Giedroyc,
who has a very similar idea.
A very similar idea about nationhood,
which is its fundamentally
a political commitment,
fundamentally about political action.
So why am I dwelling on this so much?
I'm doing this so much because
you've seen in this class
how Ukraine is a result of,
and sometimes the victim
of various imperial powers.
You can't make sense of
Ukraine without the Ottomans,
the Crimean Tatars.
You can't make sense of Ukraine
even without the Swedes,
if only briefly.
The Austrians certainly
matter quite a lot.
And the Germans matter, definitely,
especially in the 20th century.
The most important imperial powers
would be the Russians and the Poles.
If you look at the situation
as the Soviet Union is coming
to an end in the late 1980s,
you're down to only two
possible imperial power...
Well,
let's be nice to everybody else.
Only two possible imperial powers.
The Poles and the Russians.
And the Poles take themselves
out of the picture.
The Poles take themselves
The Poles in fall of 1990,
before Ukraine is an independent state,
before the Soviet Union
has ceased to exist,
they make up this thing of a treaty
with a country that doesn't exist.
Diplomacy can be more
interesting than you think.
They make up this instrument,
which is a kind of treaty
with Ukrainian Soviet Socialist Republic,
which says we each recognize
each other's borders.
It could seem trivial, right?
But it's not at all trivial.
What they're doing is they're
putting the border question
off the table preemptively.
And when they do this,
I should mention Solidarity again,
they're following the debate,
which has been happening
in Solidarity in the 1980s.
So the Solidarity debate
all moved in that direction.
So when comintern came
to an end in Poland,
it wasn't like in other countries
where suddenly all the
historical questions
rushed out at once and
were very hard to handle.
That was true for the
Soviet Union by the way.
In Poland it was a bit different.
The historical questions, many of them
had already been set up
like the Ukrainian question.
And so then when there was suddenly
a sovereign independent Poland,
they could make policy based
upon a previous discussion
which had already happened.
So by the time that Ukraine
does become independent
in December of '91,
there is no Polish question,
there is no Polish question.
The Poles have already declared
that they are in favor of
an independent Ukraine,
which means that from December, 1991,
to the present day,
the only potential imperial power
and of course now real imperial power.
But the only potential
imperial power is Russia.
So you see where I'm going with this.
The part of the making of modern Ukraine
is the encounter with Poland.
Part of the making of the
Ukrainian state as we know it now,
has to do with Polish-Ukrainian relations,
which since 1991 have certainly
had their ups and downs.
But the recognition of Ukraine
as an independent state
and Ukrainians as a separate people
has always been a constant.
So in Ukraine itself,
I wanna mention three
influences on political thought
in the 70s.
So as you've noticed,
I think the 70s are very
important for where we are now,
because the 70s were when
a certain generation,
which is still in power in Russia,
and Belarus was formed.
And what's crucial in Ukraine, I think,
is that that generation is no
longer in charge in Ukraine.
The people who run Ukraine now
are in their upper 30s and and lower 40s.
They're from a different generation.
This generation, which in the Soviet Union
was called stagnation
or in Czechoslovakia normalization,
this generation of the 70s,
this generation where...
This time when ideas were
thought not to matter.
When history, as I talked about last time
was thought to be over
when ideologies were all
thought to be discredited
and where cynicism was the dominant mood
that people had to try hard
to come up with some way
to think outta the box.
So at a time when East
Europeans are being invited
to just say all that really
matters is your personal...
We know, we agree with you.
There's gonna be no
glorious communist future.
We agree, we know, we admit it.
This is really existing socialism
and this is good as it gets.
But look,
cars, maybe some foreign travel,
refrigerators, television,
television was very important to this.
Television programs.
We'll give you that
and it's just gonna go on forever.
There aren't any alternatives,
that's the deal.
How do you think your way out of that?
And so this idea of normality.
In Poland,
this is important,
to be abnormal in the
70s and 80s politically,
was to be Jewish or Ukrainian.
Not really to be Jewish or Ukrainian.
I mean some of them were Jewish.
But it meant...
So normal was like, you're with the crowd.
You belong to the majority nation.
You're not causing
trouble, you're with us.
And the dissidents were all categorized
Jewish, Ukrainian, Jewish, Jewish, Jewish,
Ukrainian, Jewish,
Jewish, Jewish, Ukrainian.
'Cause that's what the
secret police really liked.
They like to have them on the outside.
So you're supposed to be normal.
You're not supposed to raise your head,
you're not supposed to raise your hand,
you're not supposed to raise your eyes,
you're not supposed to have ideas.
You're just supposed to go along
with this kind of consensus
that we're day after day
we're gonna have the same thing.
Human rights was an answer to that.
Directly an answer to that.
Directly, directly.
Because Brezhnev in 1975
wanted recognition of the status-quo.
So Brezhnev in 1975,
along with the Americans,
the Canadians, the Europeans
held a conference in Helsinki.
Very important conference,
things are still named after it today.
People still find it very motivating.
What Brezhnev wanted
was more the same forever.
So what he wanted was
for the Western powers to
acknowledge the Soviet borders
and the borders of the
East European states.
So those borders were never
recognized by anybody.
There was never a peace treaty
after the second World War
in Europe.
So what he wanted was effectively
a late peace treaty
that would legalize,
codify the status quo.
The ironic outcome of all of this
is something else.
He gets that, he gets that.
But in exchange, there are a few...
If you read it, it's an
interesting document.
If you read the Helsinki Final Act,
there are a few paragraphs in there
kind of buried,
about human rights.
And what the East Europeans did
was they said, oh, we're gonna take this
extremely seriously.
The East Europeans said,
well that's now the law of the land.
And of course they knew that
they weren't in rule of law states
and they knew that their
leaders didn't really mean it.
But nevertheless the idea of human rights
became very fruitful.
Because with human rights,
you can always find a gap
between what the state says it's doing
and what it should be doing.
With human rights you
always have an argument
coming from the person outwards
or from human dignity outwards
about the way things should be.
It gives you a different kind
of language of evaluation.
So all across Eastern Europe,
the Russians did this.
the Russian dissidents had
already been publishing
since the late 60s,
something called the
Chronicle of Current Events,
which was using human rights language.
The Czechs did this,
Charter 77 launches the
distinct career Vaclav Havel
who eventually becomes president.
The Poles did this, they had a committee,
something called the Committee
to Defend the Workers.
Ukrainians did this.
In 1976, they formed something called
the Ukrainian Helsinki Committee.
And Ukrainian Helsinki Committee.
I'm sorry, I have to be
so hasty about all this.
We're doing a thousand years
and these are fascinating figures,
but Ukrainian Helsinki Committee
makes the interesting argument
that the nationality is
part of human rights.
So it's not that the
nation is an ethnic group,
but the fact that I
wanna speak my language
or that I wanna be able to sing my songs
or I wanna be able to wear my shirt.
These things are part of
my life as an individual.
And so that national rights
are actually individual rights,
human rights.
They said lots of other things
that were much more
universalistic and conventional.
But this is a point that they made.
It's a very telling point
that the nation doesn't
have to be a collectivity,
the nation could be something
which resides in people.
And you can violate their rights
by not letting them speak their language.
So taking my school books away,
which is what happened in
the 70s in Soviet Ukraine.
The de facto not letting
me go to university
in my own language.
Not hiring me,
because I'm known to be somebody
who speaks Ukraine in public.
That these are violations of human rights.
And so the Brezhnevian language
is all technical efficiency.
History's over,
it's all about how,
it's all about efficiency.
So why don't we all just speak Russian.
'Cause that would just be easier.
How do you answer that language?
You can only answer that language
with some kind of why,
with some kind of normative position.
And human rights gave
people that language.
So one source of the political thinking,
which is gonna inform Ukraine later on
are the dissidents.
And the dissidents...
This is predictable.
The dissidents end up in the Gulag.
The Gulag is much smaller
by the 70s and 80s,
but it still exists.
There are two major camps
that Ukrainian dissidents are sent to.
And in these camps,
they encounter Ukrainian nationalists,
because those people were
sentenced to 25 year terms.
Sometimes repeatedly.
And so Ukrainian nationalists
who were sentenced in the 40s, 50s,
were fairly regularly still in the Gulag
in the 70s and 80s
and there were conversations in the Gulag
about what kind of future
Ukrainian nation there would be.
And again, I wish I could go
into more detail with this
'cause it's fascinating.
But the basic drift is that
the political nation argument wins out.
That the ethnic national
argument is seen for what it is.
And certainly the dissidents in general
have respect for the nationalists
for having taken risks,
which they certainly did
and having resisted Soviet
power which they certainly did.
But the argue, the general drift is
towards the political
characterization of the nation.
The third place that this is happening
is in the diaspora
in Canada, in the United States especially
where it's the same...
Interestingly it's the same two sides.
Where many of the people,
and this remains true,
many of the people who are very active
in the Canadian-American diaspora
come from West Ukrainian
families who are associated with
nationalist politics.
But over the decades,
the argument becomes more
about the Ukrainian state
and about how this thing,
which is Ukrainian-Soviet
socialist republic
and its present boundaries
will become an independent state
and what the politics
of that will be like.
And although this is not easy for people,
the reality of Soviet Ukraine
is that many people speak Russian.
It's a multinational country,
making an independent
state with just the idea
of ethnic Ukrainians is
gonna be pretty tricky.
And so the argument that
Ukraine is basically political,
and this is not trivial.
Also interesting...
You don't have to tell me
that you love the reading.
You don't have to tell
me you love the reading.
But at the time at least,
the adventures that Ivan
Rudnyts'kyi was making
in intellectual political history,
they were interesting.
I know I sound so defensive
for assigning you this stuff.
But it wasn't just...
You'll notice he's not just writing about
how there were Ukrainian people
and look at their songs
and it lasted forever.
That was my parody of Hrushevsky.
It's about interesting combinations
and individuals and surprising currents
that meet each other.
And it's also about contact
between Ukrainians and others.
It's international history.
So political nation means
interesting history.
It means you're working
for an interesting account
of where you came from
and maybe where you're going.
And so again, I'm abbreviating
these decades of debates.
But again, it's the political notion
of what Ukraine is gonna
be like that wins out.
And wins out before '91.
Wins out before '91,
which is very, very important,
because the Ukrainian territory
which is inherited in '91,
is indeed a complicated
and messy business.
I have to be very brief
about this, unfortunately.
So how did Ukraine become
an independent state?
Ukraine becomes an independent state,
because Gorbachev messes up his attempt
to reform the Soviet Union.
Understandably.
Gorbachev has the idea
that communism can be reformed.
As he tries to reform communism,
he realizes he has to
consolidate his own position,
because the Communist Party
is full of defacto reactionary lobbies
that will drag their feet
and defend their interests.
So he tries to build up a Soviet state.
This is from '85 to '91.
He tries to build up a Soviet state
where he's going to shift
being basically the president.
He's gonna be the head of state
and that's gonna matter.
As he does this,
the question is raised
about the federal structure
of the Soviet Union.
So as you know, going back back to 1922,
essentially the Ukrainian question
means that the Soviet Union has to be
or has to look like a federal state
with these national units.
By summer of 1991
as a new state treaty is being discussed,
this question of how
centralized or decentralized
the Soviet Union is going to be
is the thing which pushes
Soviet Conservatives
against Gorbachev and brings about a coup
where people try to bring down
his rule in August of 1991.
As a result of that,
Gorbachev is pushed into the background.
So the hero then...
His name's not even on here, but you know.
The hero then of that little episode
is a Russian communist
called Boris Yeltsin.
And what Yeltsin does
is he sees this occasion,
he leads the resistance to the coup.
Gorbachev is in his dacha.
That's where you are during a coup.
If you were read your lines,
it's coup, okay go to dacha, read book,
wait for the knock on the door,
stay in dacha, that's how it goes.
So Gorbachev is in his dacha,
Yeltsin gets on top of a tank,
famously at that age,
he could still get on top of tanks.
And the Russian military...
The Soviet military hesitates
and the coup plotters lose.
Yeltsin takes advantage of this
to pull Russia out of the Soviet Union,
which leaves Yeltsin in charge.
That's the way the Soviet
Union comes to an end.
Russia pulls itself out.
The second most important
actor in all of this
is Ukraine.
The Russian, Belarusian
and Ukrainian leaders
of the Russian, Ukrainian
Belarusian parties
meet in a forest in Belarus.
They meet because they're the heads
of the three republics of 1922,
which still exist in 1991.
So the constituent republics
of the Soviet Union
that still exist
meet to dissolve the Soviet Union.
Now the Ukraine...
So the man who does
that is Leonid Kravchuk
and Kravchuk is a party Apparatchik.
He had been responsible for ideology
born in interwar Poland
actually in the 30s, 1934 thereabouts
in Volhynia which was then in Poland.
Kravchuk represents the
most important current
in the beginning of independent Ukraine,
which are the slightly
national communists.
Because you see by...
Ukraine from 1972...
Soviet Ukraine from 1972 to 1989
had been ruled by the first
Secretary Volodymyr Shcherbyts'kyi
who was a conservative and a russifier.
Ukraine had been one of the
least reformed republics
during the Gorbachev period.
Shcherbyts'kyi was against Perestroika,
He was against Gorbachev's reforms.
When the Chernobyl nuclear reactor blew up
in 1986 in Ukraine,
this made it seem like Gorbachev's
reforms were meaningless.
One of his reforms are called Glasnost
which means transparency.
But the reactor blew up and nevertheless,
they went out for the mayday parades
and irradiated themselves in Ukraine,
because Gorbachev didn't
want anyone to know
that there had been
this terrible accident.
So Gorbachev's reforms
both in appearance and in reality
were much slower in
Ukraine than elsewhere.
So there was a very brief interval
before the Soviet Union came to an end
for Ukraine to get its politics in order.
The result is that the way
that Ukraine comes to an end
is that the Communist Party
is still the main force
and there are people shifting
at the top of the Communist Party.
This fellow Kravchuk gets in charge.
He sees his opportunity after the coup.
He has a referendum on
Ukrainian independence.
I guess this is important today.
There's a referendum on
Ukrainian independence,
which a majority votes for
in every region of Ukraine,
including Crimea by the way.
More than 90%...
This is 1991.
More than 90% in the country as a whole.
And they also have presidential elections.
And Kravchuk turns out to
be president, wonderful.
So he works this out very well.
But what he represents is
the most important current
in Ukrainian politics
at the beginning.
Which are the communists who
are able to ride this wave
and reestablish themselves
in positions of authority
inside Ukraine.
So I didn't quite get to Paul Manafort.
You guys can remind me.
Make sure we get to Paul Manafort.
Paul Manafort will probably
appear in the next lecture,
which Professor Shore is
giving about my Maidan.
She'll also be getting the bad news
that she has to do 15 years before Maidan.
'Cause I only got as far as I got.
Please make sure to read that her book,
I think it's the only
assigned reading this week.
Please make sure to do the
reading before the lecture.
Thank you very much.
(papers rustling)
(mystical music)